ありがとうございました
それでは これよりせっかくの機会ですので
質疑応答の時間をお設けさせていただきたいと思います
長老へのご質問がございましたら
手を挙げていただけますでしょうか
マイクをお渡しいたします
そうよね  あの ちょっと質問をさせていただきたいんですけども
あの 今の話の中でですね
妄想というものが非常に我々にとって危険なものであるという
こういうお話だったと思うんですけども
我々日常的に映画を見たりですね
テレビを見たり 演劇を見たり
まさに頭の中で作り上げた
まあ言ってみれば妄想みたいなものを
お金を払って見るという習慣があるんですけども
例えば週末に映画館に映画を見るということも
非常に我々にとって危険な行為ということになってくるでしょうか
お願いいたします  普通に生きている行為の一つですから
あの普通やっていることも危険といえば危険でしょうし
特別な危険ということでもないんだけど
気をつけないとね 映画見るのはいいんだけど
それは妄想の世界で感情を引き起こして
まあちょこっとしたまあ楽しみだなと
あれは別な現実の世界と違うんだよと
ちゃんと理解しておかないと
かなり危ない目に遭うことがあります
あの コンピューターゲームでね
結構精神的にされてる人いるでしょう
だから気をつけないと
気をつける程度ですね
ありがとうございます
こちら  こちら  例えば先ほどのね
ゴキブリとかでもね やっぱ蚊とか人間が殺る
そういうことですね そういう意味でですね
なんか殺生してゴキブリだったら虫を捕まえたりとかして
よくこう心配する人が多いんですけど
最近私はそれがちょっとできないになってきたんですけど
その辺のところは人間が死んでもいいのかなと
そのように取り入れたらそうなると思う
先輩に聞きましたね その辺
私どうやって対応したらいいのか
心掛けたらいいですか
我々は動物じゃないんだから
人間だから動物よりはマシな生き方をした方がいいんですよ
動物には自分と自分の周りの餌の環境しかね
見られませんね 私たちにはよく幅広く世界見えるんですよ
だからゴキブリであろうがあれであろうが風であろうが
まあ生命には違いありません
それで私だけ生きていればいいんだ
なんじらには生きる権利はどうでもいいやという動物の態度を取っちゃうと
なおさら自分の生きる権利がなくなっちゃうんです
なおさら苦しくなるんです
だから この生命の命を取れば取るほど
自分の命 長生きできる
健康でいられる能力が減って減って減っていくんです
だから それも危ない行為なんです
それからみんな殺虫剤かけたりするでしょ
そうやればやるほど その問題が大きくなるだけ
しかし 動物を殺さない態度をとると
自然の流れでそれにバランス取れてくるんです
ゴキブリがいなかったら困るんですよ
本当は 例えば細菌 細菌のせいで病気になるんだけど
細菌全部壊しちゃうと人間まで死んでしまいますよ
だから生命っていうのはお互い協力し合って生きているんです
その中で合わないものは当然ながらいますから
我々は合わないものからそこと離れれば十分ですよ
例えばヘビがいてはダメですと思うのはどういうことですか？ヘビは自分のポケットに入ることしない
森に放っておけばいいんです
あなたは森で 私はこちらでとかね
そういうわけで 動物の縄張りありますから
人間にも自分の縄張りがあります
自分の家というところ
自分の家は人間が住む家そこすごく綺麗にして整理整頓してよく
そうするとゴキブリに対してもすごい慈しみに
どこかで元気でまんま大丈夫じゃないと
こちらは人間の縄張りだから気を付けてよと
やったら危ないよという気分で優しい気持ちでいちゃうと
ゴキブリ出てこないんです
だから生命体の不思議なもの
相手に対して慈しみを広げると
向こうもこちらのことを心配するんですよ
だから面白いこと 私はものすごく文句のような感じで冗談に言ってますけど
私はひどい運命だと いつまでも犬に飼われるんだと
猫に飼われるんだと 何やこれやと
人間の立場どうなっているのかと冗談に言いますが
本当のことそうじゃないんです
みんな犬猫飼ってますけど
犬猫の気持ちは理解してないんです
私は犬を見たら 相手の気持ちやら感情やら
それを理解させてあげるんですよ
そうすると向こうはものすごく喜ぶんです
喜んで私のことで心配しようとするんです
これちょこっと迷惑なんですけど
あの一昨日すごい あの山口に行ったんだけど
面白いことあったんです
あの外でいる そこで飼っている猫がいて
私が夜電気を当てて本を読んでたんだから
この外に猫がサッと入って中に入れてくれと鳴くんです
で 分かったんで この鳴き声は中に入れてくれってこと
お寺の人々も隠れて言うんです
外でいる猫だからね それで私は中に入れたんです
入れたら喜んで遊んで遊んで
もう 12 時を過ぎてる
猫が一番元気な時間だからね
遊んで遊んでも遊ぼう遊ぼうとかね
遊んじゃいかな 私は寝るんだからね
あなたはちょっと寝たらどうですか？と言っても
本人が寝たくない それでも私が寝たらもう寝てるなとわかって
この心いっぱいあるのにかかわらず
枕のこちらにその辺で寝ていたんです
それから私は朝冗談ですら言ったんですね
今日はなんかぼろっ入ってる袋をね
この枕のそばに置いといて
寝たような感じですと
そうしたら これはまあ捨てていって
お寺の人たちは猫を洗ったんですね
お風呂に入れてあげたんです
お風呂に入れたから 私はまあ今日来たっても大丈夫だということを
私は今日は来ないんだよと
もうせっかく洗ってもらったんだから
自慢げに他の猫たちと一緒に遊んでるんですよって知らせて
その通り来なかったんです
私の気持ち読めるんです
それで次の日 猫は来ると待っていたのに
それで寝られなかったと
来なかったんだよ 外 それで次の日
また来るんですよ 次の日で猫のやりとり何なのかというと
私は寝るまで見守ってあげて
グーグーと寝たところで出て行ったんです
それに窓を開けておかないと
だから部屋に入って もう窓を開けておくとずっと鳴くんです
窓ちょっと開けたら出て行かない
それを喜んでまたぐるぐるぐるぐる回ったりすると
あんた出て行かないの一瞬寝ようよって
もう閉めたんです 閉めたらもう寝かせてくれない
まだ鳴く そうするとまた窓をこうやって削ったりして
また開けておいたんです
そしたら出て行けないでしょ
窓開けたら風来るんだからね
夜と言って寝ようよ このいる時間だから引いてくれた
それでまた閉めて また寝た
また それどうしましたかというと
一応まあしょうがないから開けといたんです
開けといても出て行かない
で 蚊が来るのに私はもう寝たんです
寝て じーっと寝てる 猫が何やってるのか
それで猫がじーっと尻尾を振りながら待ってる
私が寝るまで だから目を開けてみると猫がいるってこと
それでちょっとまあ寝そびれたいんだから目を閉じていたんです
閉じてる間でこそっと出て行くんです
えらいこっちゃ 猫に寝かせてもらおうという
だから人間の立場どうなっているのかよ
だからそれって何のこともなく
やっぱり猫の気持ち 私が理解してあげたんだから
猫もその自分なりに頑張ってるんですよ
ある日 犬から私はプレゼントもらったことがあるんです
ある犬のことをものすごい心配して面倒見てあげたんです
猫も犬も私のことを心配してて
ある日どこか行って 生ゴミがあるところで探して探して
でっかい牛の骨一つ見つけて持ってきます
それでじーっと持ってきて私に来るのです
私は何やっての？これ持ってきなさい
持ってきなさいって持って行ったら
そうするとあげるような感じだから冗談だと思って手を出すとちゃんと来るわけです
気持ち悪いんだけど 自分は人間だからね
これは犬がおいしく食べるものでしょとなって
マットの上にね 置いたんです
置いたらすぐまた取ってまた来るんです
また戻って またまたマットの上に置いたんです
置いたら回目に犬がこれ取って私のベッドの真ん中に置いて出てくる
それでわかったんだ これは私に対してね
犬のプレゼントやと だから別に嫌な猫
犬っていうわけじゃないでしょ
犬の立場から見れば 犬にとっては世界一おいしくて楽しくてたまらんですよ
骨一つ見つかったら だから自分にもらった
せっかく拾った一番いいもの
じゃあこの人にあげましょうと
だから面白いんですよ
お互いに慈しみで生きてみると迷惑ないんです
だからこの 本当に面白いんですよ
虫たちみんなお互いを理解しておくと
よくその場を空けてくれるという
人間にはちょっと許してあげようということがあるんですよ
しかし 我々はサーってスプレーで殺虫かけるんだからね
これって人間は人間らしい行為じゃないんです
我々は人間だから もうちょっと全ての生命のことをね
心配な気持ちで助けてあげなくちゃあかんでしょう
だから犬猫やってますよ
例えばこの勝手に お寺とかたくさん捨て犬捨て猫がいるんですよ
で 捨て猫なのに また新しい猫を捨てられちゃうと
おっぱいあげるんですよ
全く知らない人間にも
だからこの捨て犬捨て猫同士でも
お互いに協力し合って面倒を見てあげたりするのに
人間って何でしょうかね
だから私は本当に時々びっくりするんで
動物なのによく仲間のことを心配する
おっぱいあげるってことは大変なことでしょう
自分の体壊れるでしょうに
子供を飲んでないのにおっぱいあげちゃう
でも気にしないそうです
体骨にだらけにボロボロになるんですよ
それでもやっぱりまだまだおっぱいした方がいいというもの見つけたら
時々猫はね 雌猫をおっぱいあげるんですよ
だから出ますよ そういう面白いこと
そういうわけで いずれも人間っていうのは機関銃やら鉄砲やら原子爆弾やらね
抱えていて あるいは我々はいつでも殺虫剤抱えて生きているということは
ものすごいかっこ悪い
恐ろしい生き方なんです
競争の生き方なんです
必要な だから心配あるでしょ
迷惑じゃないか それで毒蛇繁殖するんじゃないかって
それは心配いりません
そういう繁殖しません
心の慈しみが一番最初にやった慈悲の気持ちが入ったら
驚きますよ 世界一ぱいですけど
なんでみんな協力してくれるんじゃないかってよくわかるんですよ
例えば 慈悲の気持ちある人が植えた種の実が本当に美味しいんですよ
それ一つ食べただけでも体に映えるんですよ
簡単に 野菜にも毒もありますけど
我々気持ちが憎しみ怒りですから
何食べても体に悪い物質溜まるんです
優しい心がある人が何食べても
その食べ物にある体にいいものだけ取って
悪いものは何のことなく排出してくれます
ですから 慈悲の瞑想する人は確実に健康になります
長生きします それで生命が助けてくれたり
協力してくれたりする
だから野生の動物でも来て遊んでくれますよ
一人でいて寂しい 寂しいなと思っちゃうと
やっぱり動物は気をつけますよ
人間のこと怖いんだから
私が一人でどこかにいる場合は
誰も他の人は来ないなという環境にいる場合は一人でいたことはないんです
いつでもどこかで どこかで誰かがいるよ
動物がいる うろうろうろうろしてたりする
だから まあそれを見ながらいると
別にもう楽しいです だから
この我々はそういう慈しい世界をね
創った方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
ありがとうございました
ありがとうございます
3個と思うのですが  1つお話を聞きたいのは
あの ...苦しみがあって
生きると死ぬと死ぬはまあそれなりにわかるわけですけども
病気についてはどのように考えたらいいのかという質問が多くまして
特に内科的や精神的な病気に関してどのように理解したらいいのかというようなことをお伺いしたい
ちょうどのお話をさせていただいた
あの病気になるっていうことはもう避けられないこと
体っていうのは この物質は無常でしょうし
無常だから無常っていうことは変化する
変化するということは不完全ということです
完全なら変化しない それで細胞も変化して変化して変化していく
それからこの世界 宇宙の中でこのエントロピーという法則があるんですよ
変化するんだけど エントロピーがあるんですね
いわゆるこのスピード減るんです
だから細胞を変化しに生きるということは
細胞の中の物質を外へ出して
外の物質を中に入れることなんです
それがずっと一定のスピードで遅くなれば
もう長生きいくらでもできます
しかし 問題は細胞にもエントロピーがあるんです
それで中の物質出すスピードが減るんです
外の物質入れるスピードが減るんです
いきなりたちまち細胞が壊れて死ぬんです
で 中に悪い物質が溜まるし
それ置き換える新しい物質が入るのはほんの少しでしょうし
だからもう必ず死ななくてはいけないということが法則です
だから病気になるということはごく自然な現象で
我々はそう見ないんだから
病気が問題になるんです
まず 病気になることは当たり前
例えばお釈迦様があの
用を足したい 用を足すことも病気だと教えるんです
お腹が空くことも病気だよ
喉が渇くことも病気だよ
お釈迦様の病気のリストにそれまで入ってるんです
お腹が空くこと 用を足すこと
それも病気なんだ だから病気は軽く見ているわけじゃないんです
しかし 我々はお腹が空くことは病気じゃなくて
逆に元気だと勘違いしてるんです
じゃない それは病気の一つなんです
それで私たちは お腹が空いたら全然心配も何にもないんです
ただご飯食べて終わった
喉が渇いたら全然心配しない
水を飲んで終わっちゃう
他の病気になったって同じ気持ちになってください
どうしたことないです
あ そうか では そうどうしよう
例えばあの えっと えっと
ローマ字が出てきて これ出てきたら治療ないんだから
もうもうどんどんひどくなったり
ああ そうか 足が動かないんだ
では 杖を使いましょうとかね
それで十分です 別にどうったことないです
心臓が弱くなってきたら
ああ そうか ではまあ適当に気をつけて生活するそう
だ だから病気はここ当たり前の
お腹が空くことと同じことだと思っちゃえば随分楽になります
たとえがんになったから驚いちゃって興奮し
興奮するんでしょうかね
びっくりしてもう怖くなって
それで死んじゃいますからね
ああ がんですかね ああ
そうか わかったわかった
そういう風に落ち着いていられれば
そんなに大したことないんですよ
反対すること どうしても死ぬということは確実ですからね
エントロピー法則もありますからね
どうしようもないんです
それから なんで我々は高血圧になったり
心臓発作を起こしたり
脳出血をしたりするんですかね
これは欲 体を維持するために食べているんじゃないんです
美味しいんだから食っているんです
みんなごちそうを食べてるんだから
自分も食べてるんです
今流行ってるんだからって食べてるんです
おかしないいところなんですよ
だから 脂ばっかし食べたりする
だから欲で食べてるんだから
怒りで食べてるんだから
見栄で食べてるんだから
嫉妬で食べてるんだから
食べるものはほとんど毒になるんです
毒だから体はそれはいただかないんです
しかし 入ったものはあちこち溜まってるんです
だから体はゴミだらけ
だからどうやって血管が動くんですかね
もうゴミだらけでしまってるんだから
だからお釈迦様は言うのは食べる時は欲を捨てて人は食べなくてはいけない
だから体を維持するために
管理するために必要な栄養分をいただきますと受け入れます
それによって目を張ったりとか
人を蹴ったりぶん殴ったりとかね
そんなことはしませんよと
その代わりに この食べ物を作ってくれたすべての生物に対して慈しみを抱きましょう
そういうふうに思って適宜だけ食べたら
これでは余計な現代病気は一つも起こりません
それでも悪夢間違ったり
もう心臓が弱くなったり
胃が弱くなったりというのは当たり前
エントロピーで当たり前で病気になってしまいますけど
ひどい病気にはなりません
だから体の病気の場合は
もう今までの生き方が悪いんだからね
いろいろがんもそうなんですよ
生き方と精神の問題から出てくることで
だからまあ病気は当たり前だと思って
まあどうったことはない
自然の流れ落ち着いていますと
早くガンで五年にするならば
まあいいんじゃないんですか
一年だったら一年だったらまあいいでしょう
まあもう短期間で だから苦労は一年だけで済みますから
で 気楽でいれば大変 心の安らぎが
死ぬまで残るんです 安らぎな心で死ぬ人は
次の生まれ 安らぎのところで生まれます
それで精神的な病気の場合は
精神的な病気は絶対ダメです
肉体的な病気はどうったことない
心の病気だけは絶対ダメです
お釈迦様が心の病気を治す治療をする医者なんです
心は完全な健康になったら悟りに達して究極な幸福に達するんです
だから精神的な病気には仏教は徹底的に治療するんです
我々が今悩んでいる精神病気すべてが妄想の結果なんです
対人関係の問題あるとか
もう高層恐怖症とか あれこれとかね
閉じ込まれると引きこもりとかね
それからまあいっぱいありますね
社交不安という まあ最近その言葉よくわからないけども出ていますけど
あの他人覚悟とかね それで妄想です
だから何か妄想する その妄想することによって精神的に病気になります
だからもう妄想しないこと
これ慣れてますからやりますけど
ギリギリ訓練して訓練して妄想することをとことんとことんやめてみる
もうみるみるうちに病気が治る
精神的な病気 午後紹介しますけど
ヴィパッサナー瞑想なんかは
いくら精神的にぐちゃぐちゃにされてる方でも
やってみるとすぐ 1日
2日  3日で治るんです
しかし 正常な精神状態になっても
仏教はそれが我慢しません
正常でいたっても病気ですから
悟りに達するまでやらなくちゃいけないんです
我々の正常を仏教から見れば相当な精神病気なんです
しかし 正常より以下で
分裂病やらいろいろ出てくること
もう困るでしょう それも妄想を控えることでなくなるんです
お医者さんがするのは薬をあげて脳が働かないようにする
それでなんとなく病気が抑えたことになるだけで治らないんです
そうすると薬依存するんです
で 人生は捨てなくちゃいけない
もう頭が動かない人間だから何もできなくなるんです
仏教は瞑想で頭働かせるんです
頭働かせて妄想をやめさせちゃうんです
そうすると ものすごい元気で幸福な
明るい活発な人間になります
だから精神病だけはまあとんでもないダメです
肉体的な病気は放っておきますよという
そんなのは当たり前だということの立場なんです
ありがとうございました
女性の方が  と申します
本日はいいお話をありがとうございました
2つほどお聞きしたいのですが
まず 1つは 私たちが生まれてきた目的とか
人生の目的というのはですね
苦しみを味わうことと
それを減らしていくという
そのことをこいという形でいいんでしょうか
そしてもう一つはですね
先ほど妄想で妄想を減らすと同時に能力が向上していくというお話だったんですけれども
この妄想を減らすことで
いらない貪瞋痴を減らし
苦しみから逃れることはわかるのですが
その能力の向上というのは
能力とは一体どのようなことをおっしゃられるのでしょうか
えーと 生きるということは苦しみをできるだけ増やす
増やすことだから 生きる目的はバカバカらしいということですね
だから生きる目的は苦しみをなくす
乗り越えるということに強引にしなくちゃいけないんです
そうすると ものすごいしっかり生きていられます
例えば みんな悪いことしたくないんだけど
悪いことしますね 嘘つきたくないんだけど
嘘つきますね それで後でひどい目に遭ったりする
でも生きることは苦しみをなくす
なくす目的にすると思っちゃうと
おのずと我々は良い人間になっちゃう
おのずといい人間になって
どんどん苦しみをなくす方向へ行くんです
成長します ですから 生きることには本来は目的はありません
生きるということはバカバカらしくて
苦しみを増やす行為だけ
ですから あえて目的を作る
苦しみをなくそうではないか
乗り越えようではないか
そうなってくると では私はどうすればいいかということは出てくる
だったら嫉妬してはあかんぞとか
喧嘩してはあかんぞとかね
怠けてはあかんぞとかね
で いろんなものが出てきて
良い人間になります それは第1位
2番目は何でしたっけ？忘れちゃった
能力のこと 能力というのはいろいろ考えられます
例えば 生きている上で
生まれたら死ぬまで生きていなくない
生きていかなくちゃいけないんですよ
それがスムーズに生きるならば
結構能力があるんですよ
例えば 家で飼っていた猫を森に捨ててみてください
家に飼っていたんだから
大怠け者でわがままで
能力がないんですよ だから森に捨てちゃうと生きられないんです
それでも能力のある猫がなんとかして生きられるんです
だからこの能力というのは
その程度であれば十分ですよ
我々人間というのは 仕事に行く
仕事っていうのは 人間が食べるために必要なことですね
だったら仕事を上手にできるならば
給料をもらって別に後ろめたいとは感じないでしょう
ビシビシ仕事したならば
給料もらいたってのはいいと
こんなのもっともらいたいんだよとかね
いう すごい気分がいい状態で生きていられます
だから仕事に能力があった方がいいということになります
で 我々は人間 生で食べられませんので
料理しなくちゃいけない
今 胃が弱いんだからね
そういうわけで 料理が下手だったらちょっと困るんじゃないの
料理が下手な人はすごい高いお金で料理を外で食べなくちゃいけないんですね
あれは健康を見て作っているものじゃないので
レストランというのは
お客さんに美味しい味を食べさせにご飯を食べさせて金儲かりたいだけ
だから健康に悪いのは当たり前
自分で料理作る能力がない場合は
店のものしか食べるしか方法なくなっちゃいますね
ですから ちょこっとしたことで簡単な料理できるようになれば
それも能力なんです そういうことで
能力の 第1ということは
まあしっかり問題なく生きられる能力なんです
音楽家にはいろいろ発想があればかなり売れますね
そうすると金が入って生きられます
画家にはいろんなアイディアが出てくるならば
面白い絵を描けますね
描けるんだけど アイディアがなかったら終わりですよ
人生は 画家の人生は 腕はありますけど
何描こうかと 何のイメージも出てこないならばもう終わり
だから それぞれが我々に生きている上で必要な能力
もう一つっていうのは
人間の能力っていうのは限ったものじゃないんです
妄想を減らしてみると
すごいいろんなことをできます
一番お釈迦様が重視する能力っていうのは
怒りをなくす能力 欲をなくす能力
嫉妬を消す能力 人を憎しむことをなくす能力
たとえ敵であっても 心を込めて幸せでいてほしいと
と思える能力 そういう心を清らかにする能力が
どうしてもブッダが必要としているのです
そういう 2つの能力だと考えた方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
ありがとうございました
最後に一つだけよろしいでしょうか
もう一人の方だけ はい
じゃあこちらの方  今日はお話ありがとうございました
用語に言葉について質問があるんですけれども
ヴィパッサナーというのは英語のマインドフルネスとか
あと日本語の正念というものと同じようだと考えてよろしいでしょうか？その関係について教えてください
ヴィパッサナーっていうのは
パーリ語を分析すると
ヴィっていうのは明確に
パッサナーっていうのは観察する
だから明確に観察していくっていう意味なんです
だから明確に観察するためには
マインドフルネスです
でも気づいている状態が必要ですから
英訳はマインドフルネスということにするんです
ヴィパッサナーにはまだ別な英訳もいくつかあります
だから観察するの observation ですね
明確にということは まあパーフェクトとかケアとかね
いろいろ単語使いますけどね
だからまあパーフェクト observation とか何とかでも構いません
漢訳では承認とか何とかそういうことはあります
我々はだいたい気づきという言葉を使っています
ですね はい  ありがとうございました
それでは これをもちまして
アルバムでスマナサーラ長老による講演会の部を終了させていただきます
長老 どうもありがとうございました
[拍手]